Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, on a une question de Jean-Luc,
qu'on va aller écouter :
« Est-ce que les Autochtones
vont jamais s'en sortir? »
Alors Jean-Luc, tu me demande si les Autochtones vont réussir à s'en sortir et je peux te dire que déjà, on le fait.
On est encore ici, 500 ans
après la colonisation,
malgré justement les guerres biologiques,
malgré les pensionnats, la Loi sur les Indiens,
toutes les formes de colonisation
qui nous ont été imposées.
On est encore ici. Donc je pense
qu'on commence à prouver qu'on sait s'en sortir.
On doit maintenant guérir
de toutes ces attaques sur notre identité,
notre langue, notre culture.
Je pense que comme n'importe quel citoyen,
oui on va traîner avec nous
ces savoirs ancestraux, parce que, comparé
à d'autres savoirs qui nous ont été imposés,
ces savoirs-là ont fait leurs preuves.
ont aidé à notre survie
et justement,
ont aidé à la fierté,
et à notre existence aujourd'hui.
C'est ce qui nous donne encore envie
d'aller vers l'avant et de penser encore
aux 7 futures générations. Et ce qui est vraiment heureux, c'est que maintenant,
beaucoup de gens reconnaissent
que d'avoir voulu éteindre ces savoirs-là,
ça a été une erreur que le Québec
et le Canada, et les États-Unis aussi, ont fait.
Et maintenant, ils veulent intégrer
les savoirs des Premières Nations
pour ce qui est de la conservation des animaux,
pour ce qui est de la survie dans
les changements climatiques.
Donc, je pense qu'on s'en sort plutôt bien.
Et ce qui fait qu'on s'en sort bien,
c'est que justement on a encore la main tendue,
on est encore connaissants de nos savoirs
et on est encore très fiers et qu'on fait cette
transmission-là. Et maintenant,
on la fait aussi avec la population québécoise
et canadienne.
J'espère, Jean-Luc, que ç'a pu aider
à ta question pour le grand angle
que ça doit couvrir,
mais je te dirais que plus les gens vont s'ouvrir
aux cultures des Premières Nations,
plus ils vont comprendre
que ce n'est pas nous de nous intégrer.
Je vous souhaite une très belle semaine
et n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos.
N'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions,
surtout, à Parole autochtone.